muy buenos días Pues usted bien lo decía
más de 200 puntos de manifestación a lo
largo y ancho de todo el país algunas
marchas que ya comenzaron en varias
regiones especialmente en el sur del
país Aquí en la capital se espera que me
esperes que comience sobre las dos de la
tarde desde aquí desde la Plaza de la
República en total debería haber cerca
de un millón de personas que
manifestarán el día de hoy Esto según
las estimaciones de las autoridades
Aunque por lo general esas estimaciones
siempre están por debajo de las cifras
esperadas de por parte de los sindicatos
hace un momento con algunos de las
personas que ya están acá esperando que
arranque esta manifestación dicen que a
pesar de de que finalmente el trámite
legislativo continúa en el senado ellos
creen que todavía la calle tiene
posibilidad de presionar al gobierno de
que no están de acuerdo con esta reforma
pensional y sobre todo que se les está
quitando la libertad de poder disfrutar
de su vida una vez hayan terminado todos
los años de trabajo una persona que
trabaja en el en la industria
Automotriz ahora como usted bien lo
decía Pues los sindicatos no fueron
recibidos por Emanuel se llevaron
digamos un portazo algo que para ellos
pues muestra de alguna manera El
desprecio que tiene el gobierno hacia lo
que está sucediendo en la calle Manuel
les dijo el diálogo continúa abierto
está la posibilidad de hablar pero no
les doy una cita y sobre todo Esta es
una reforma que tiene que hacerse cueste
lo que cueste y de todas maneras hay que
esperar a que esta llegue a término en
el parlamento y mañana domingo el senado
continuará el examen del proyecto de ley
para reformar las pensiones cuéntenos
Más allá de esto Cuáles son las próximas
etapas legislativas
Así es de hecho el senado tiene hasta
mañana de la medianoche Pero hoy ya
comenzó también a trabajar desde las
nueve treinta de la mañana que
recordemos que además el gobierno
utilizó Está sacando sus cartas más
duras en materia legislativa con un
artículo que les permite bloquear de
alguna manera el voto es decir que el
senado ya no puede ir estudiando
artículo por artículo ni tampoco
enmienda por enmienda sino que tiene que
hacerlo sobre la totalidad del texto
como les decía tienen hasta el próximo
mediodía a media noche de mañana luego
el miércoles será la reunión de la
comisión paritaria siete diputados siete
senadores que tendrán que ponerse de
acuerdo sobre ya la última versión de
este proyecto de ley y este texto ya
pasará a ser votado a la asamblea y a la
senado En todo caso todo esto tiene que
hacerse antes del próximo 26 de Marzo
porque lo otro es el gobierno bien ha
dicho que no tendrá miedo en utilizar el
otro artículo el cuarenta y nueve tres
que ya utilizó en a lo largo de este año
y a finales del año pasado que le
permite finalmente hacer que se apruebe
este artículo sin necesidad de que sea
votado Así que como verán viene ya está
recta final de toda esta situación sobre
esta reforma pensional pero en todo caso
ese artículo siete del que usted hablaba
que es el corazón de esta reforma ya fue
aprobado esta semana por el senado